en este vídeo continuaremos viendo los
diferentes escenarios que podemos
encontrar cuando hay cambios tanto en la
oferta como en la demanda ahora veremos
la sección de abajo de estas gráficas y
pensaremos en situaciones en las que
ambas curvas cambian imaginemos un
escenario en donde aumenta la oferta y
disminuye la demanda quizás nuevos
productores entran al mercado aumentando
la oferta y al mismo tiempo se publica
un artículo donde dice que el helado es
dañino para la salud por lo que
disminuye la demanda que ocurrirá con el
precio y la cantidad de equilibrio pausa
en el vídeo y piensen en ello si la
oferta aumenta la curva de la oferta se
desplaza hacia la derecha como lo vimos
aquí arriba esto es ese 2 y si disminuye
la demanda las personas estarán
dispuestas a comprar una menor cantidad
por lo que la curva se desplaza hacia
abajo oa la izquierda donde les sea más
ilustrativo verlo esto es de 2 donde
estará el nuevo punto de equilibrio
vemos que está aquí y es claro que el
precio disminuyó pero qué pasa con la
cantidad aquí tenemos algo interesante y
dependerá de cómo lo dibujemos si no
conocemos los números exactos
aquí lo pude haber dibujado de manera
que la cantidad permaneciera igual o si
lo dibujo así podría verse que la
cantidad aumentó un poco pero si dibujo
la curva de demanda así la cantidad
disminuye un poco en esta situación es
seguro que el precio disminuye hay más
competencia entre oferentes y hay menor
demanda pero no está claro lo que ocurre
con la cantidad en esta situación
podríamos decir que la cantidad está
indeterminada supongamos que disminuye
la oferta y aumenta la demanda que
pasará en ese caso pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en ello si disminuye la oferta
toda la curva de oferta se va a mover a
la izquierda y hacia arriba pues dado el
precio de equilibrio
habrá menos oferta y la demanda
aumentará dado el mismo precio de
equilibrio habrá gente dispuesta a pagar
más por lo que nuestra nueva curva de
demanda es ahora de 2 está arriba y a la
derecha y el nuevo punto de equilibrio
al menos como lo he dibujado se
encuentra aquí acá está el precio 2 y
por acá está la cantidad 2 y lo que
tenemos es que claramente el precio
aumenta eso tiene sentido porque
disminuye la oferta y más personas
quieren comprar qué va a pasar con la
cantidad nuevamente va a depender de
cómo dibujamos la curva podemos hacer
que la cantidad aumente un poco
disminuya o no cambie por lo que
necesitamos conocer la información
específica de las curvas para saber qué
es lo que ocurre con la cantidad en este
escenario tanto la oferta como la
demanda van a aumentar cuando la oferta
aumenta la curva se mueve hacia abajo oa
la derecha esto es ese 2 y la demanda va
a aumentar por lo que para el precio que
tenemos las personas están dispuestas a
pagar más o para cierto precio las
personas tomarán una mayor cantidad así
que la nueva curva de demanda se moverá
hacia arriba oa la derecha y ahora aquí
tenemos el nuevo punto de equilibrio no
cabe duda de que la cantidad de
equilibrio aumenta pero ahora el precio
es ambiguo dependiendo de como dibujemos
esta curva podemos hacer que el precio
no cambie aumente un poco o disminuya un
poco así que el precio es ambiguo
finalmente imaginemos un escenario en el
que disminuye la oferta y la demanda la
curva de oferta se mueve arriba
izquierda nuevamente podemos verlo como
que para cierto precio estamos
dispuestos a ofrecer una menor cantidad
y si la demanda disminuye entonces para
cierto precio las personas demandarán
menor cantidad la curva de demanda luce
así ahora aquí está el punto de
equilibrio la cantidad de equilibrio 2
ha disminuido sin duda alguna lo que
tiene sentido porque hay menos oferta y
la gente quiere menos así que la
cantidad disminuye pero nuevamente el
precio es ambiguo pues depende de cómo
no dibuje puedo hacer que el precio
permanezca igual o aumente o disminuya
dependerá de los detalles y los
comportamientos de las curvas y no
olvidemos etiquetar todos los elementos
de la gráfica primero porque la hace más
fácil de leer y segundo porque si
estamos realizando un examen hay que
etiquetar todo en la gráfica el título
de la gráfica el punto de equilibrio el
precio y la cantidad de equilibrio las
curvas los ejes coordinados y cuando
tenemos un desplazamiento
debemos dibujar ese cambio usando
flechas que indiquen hacia dónde es el
desplazamiento de la curva de oferta o
de demanda
etiquetar todos estos elementos cuando
resuelvan un examen nos vemos el otro
vídeo